Ukraine's military says Russia has
pulled some of its troops back from
front lines near the southern city of
Hassan but keep officials said on
Thursday that two civilians were killed
by continued shelling of the area they
also warned that a Russian aerial
assault is being planned which could
worsen shortages of water electricity
and heating across Ukraine DW's Jan
Phillips shots visited two towns in the
country's East
he operated on the injured down here and
he helped women give birth at times
surgeon Yuri kudzniasov was the only
doctor left as easium was under heavy
fire he was in charge of everything this
is upstairs patients still arrive and
medical staff have reclaimed some of the
less damaged rooms that the coming
months are worrying
we've got to survive the winter period
now
we've got to somehow maintain our
Medical Care at a high level during that
time
unfortunately we cannot rely on the
hospital's centralized heating system
anymore
but we've started to buy electric
heaters
at least in easium the attacks are
already weeks old it's a different story
in cook yansk around 40 kilometers North
several people were hurt by artillery
fire the morning we visited this is
where they would normally go an attack
ruined the local Polyclinic just a few
days before the injured have to leave
town the head doctor shows us what is
left of this office
there's simply no excuse for this it
looks like they want to destroy the
civilian population
there has never been military personnel
at the Polyclinic only civilians we just
provided medical treatment to normal
people in need
foreign
at one of the few ATMs in the town that
still works those normal people see
their home being destroyed around them
and that the temperatures drop
every day when you leave your home you
see new Devastation and this was such a
flourishing City once
my Village out of town had a very nice
Medical Center but it doesn't work
anymore
sometimes doctors visit but we don't
have any doctors of our own anymore
Dr Cinco says he's looking for a place
to set up a temporary clinic but he says
the Russians didn't just damage the
building in the attack
the people who work in our medical
facility have come under Fire three
times now
imagine three times frankly people are
frightened
the ground Russian destruction of
Civilian infrastructure feels
increasingly like a strategy
for the people living here near the
front it could become a matter of life
or death
we can take a closer look at this with
Mike Martin a war studies senior fellow
at King's College London morning Mike
good to see you
um you know we can see in that report
Russia is pummeling Ukraine's
infrastructure and the Ukraine's
ukrainians are clearly really feeling it
now how long can the the country and its
resources realistically stand up to this
I think Anya actually realistically I
think they are going to stand up to it
um it's going to be a very long cold
winter for the Ukrainian civilians and
that will inevitably mean that some of
those civilians perhaps the old or the
infirm are likely to die because of the
lack of you know the services like power
and health
um but I don't think that this is going
to stop the Ukrainian military fighting
I think I think actually the opposite is
going to happen the more that the
Russians inflict damage on Ukrainian
civilians the harder the Ukrainian
military is likely to fight back
we heard from the U.S from French
president macron's visit to the U.S that
both
um the U.S president and the French
President are committed to holding
Russia to account for widely documented
atrocities and war crimes can you talk
to us about this how will they
realistically be able to hold Russia to
account
so International prosecutions for for
war crimes or crimes against humanity of
which Russia has has committed a number
in this conflict the reality is that
these prosecutions only get carried out
and inflicted upon losers right so
countries that lose Wars so if we have a
peace deal in Ukraine um that almost
certainly means that we won't be
prosecuting Russia the only way that
Putin and his senior generals are going
to be brought to account is if Ukraine
effectively wins the war Russian forces
leave and then those Avenues can be
pursued through the international courts
otherwise it's very very very unlikely
to happen okay we've heard from a senior
advisor to president zielinski that um
as many as 13 000 Ukrainian troops have
been killed in the war the US on the
other hand is suggesting that it may be
as many as 100 000 casualties why is
there such a difference between these
two estimates
it's it's very very difficult um to
estimate casualties in War
um from the start of the conflict the
ukrainians have been very very secretive
about their numbers of troops numbers of
casualties for obvious reasons because
that impacts upon their domestic morale
it's not really clear why originally
these comments came from Ursula Von
Delan and then were picked up by the US
it's not clear why they are citing a
hundred thousand although a very widely
uh documented number of Russian
casualties is is about a hundred
thousand and the Russians have been much
more careless with their troops so I
would imagine the Ukrainian figure would
be perhaps fifty thousand
okay all right Mike Martin from King's
College London thanks so much for your
time this morning
thank you